this video is kindly sponsored by keeps
find out more later on hey 42 here
life is full of awful events on any
given day you might get hit by a bus
mulled by a tiger or asphyxiated by a
vengeful olive in your martini you could
get dumped fired or thrown into prison
for indecent exposure again
your flat white could be cold and your
beer could be warm you might put your
duvet into the cover the wrong way
around and have to start all over again
the list is endless and quite frankly
bloody terrible but as dreadful as these
experiences are and as hard as it is to
believe there are even bigger incidents
that threaten not only your well-being
but the safety of the entire human race
a giant asteroid strike could be game
over for life as we know it just as the
dinosaurs oh no that's right you can't
they're all dead nuclear war could see
millions die instantly as bombs pelt the
world's biggest cities in an atomic
reign with the rest of us to follow
later as the planet's living creatures
perish in the famine of a nuclear winter
we could also see mass species
extinction destructive weather anomalies
and wars over water resulting from
climate change
finally there's the prospect of a
humanity-ending virus that spreads
across the globe at lightning pace and
eradicates anything that walks on two
legs and likes to watch netflix rewind
to the start of 2020 and a lot of people
thought we were already living through
that last doomsday scenario but bad as
it's been covert 19 clearly isn't the
virus to end all viruses or at least it
isn't the one to end all humans
so
what is scientists have a lot of
different possible answers to that
question but to me it's obvious
zombies
now i want to take a minute to talk
about hair loss because i've had people
close to me start to lose their hair as
early as their twenties and it's always
an upsetting experience
if you're in the same boat then you're
not alone did you know two out of three
guys will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
but the best thing you can do to prevent
hair loss is take the initiative now and
do something about it whilst you've
still got hair left i like keeps because
it makes treatment super easy by
delivering your hair loss medication
every three months directly to your door
so you can say goodbye to awkward doctor
visits and waiting in pharmacy checkout
lines
there's a reason that keeps has more 5
star reviews in any of its competitors
and hundreds of thousands of men trusts
them for their hair loss prevention
medication if you're like me you're
probably not ready to lose your hair
just yet but prevention is key the
faster you act the faster you'll see
results and the sooner you start using
keeps the more hair you'll save
so if you're noticing that you're losing
your hair do something about it
for a limited time go to keeps.com
forward slash 42 or click the link in
the description below to receive 50
off your first order
anybody who's watched a few crappy b
grade horror movies knows that it's only
a matter of time before we're all in the
middle of a zombie apocalypse caused by
a mystery virus that turns people into
undead monsters hungry for human flesh
so it's probably a good idea for us to
start planning for the inevitable
when the zombies come what should we do
and more importantly will our species
survive
well
i'm sorry to break it to you but science
says no or at least a study conducted by
a bunch of physics students at leicester
university does
in fact according to their calculations
when the zombie tide inevitably rises
we don't even stand a chance
after just 100 days there will be fewer
than 300 humans left outnumbered by
zombies more than a million to one
within a year the human race would be
wiped out entirely to arrive at this
cheerful conclusion the students used a
model called s i r sir named after the
three categories of people that are
identified when mapping a contagious
disease s or those susceptible to being
infected i or those that are infected
and are or those that have recovered
it's a standard model used in
epidemiology which is one of those
abstract scientific disciplines you'd
never even heard of two years ago but
now sounds as familiar as zoology
psychology or proctology
that's because an epidemiologist studies
the cause spread and control of diseases
in populations you'll remember them from
the news broadcaster of the last 18
months or so
they were the ones who kept arguing with
each other about who should stay at home
and for how long
the leicester university study replaced
the standard sir model susceptible
infected and recovered with the more
apocalypse appropriate s z d model
susceptible zombie dead
their calculations were based on the
assumption that each zombie would bite
only one susceptible person per day with
a 90 chance of infecting them with the
zombie virus they also left standard
human birth and death rates out of the
equation because quite frankly in the
space of 100 days what difference would
that make after the study was published
a few people made some smart
observations about how adaptable humans
have been as a species and the
likelihood of us finding clever ways to
respond to the army of the undead so the
physicists re-ran the numbers this time
assuming that people would get better
over time at killing and avoiding
zombies they also figured that humans
would make babies faster than normal
presumably because nothing turns people
on more than hiding from a herd of
walking corpses under the new conditions
the research team calculated humans
would actually win taking just over two
and a half years to wipe out the zombie
swines then with some dedicated shagging
it would take only 25 more years for the
human population to start recovering
from the onslaught happy days
but that is a massive swing in fortunes
for humankind so let's take a closer
look at some of the factors that might
come into play when predicting our
chances of surviving a zombie apocalypse
let's start by looking at the disease
itself evolutionary biologists think
viruses naturally evolve to find an
optimal virulence
which means the perfect balance between
multiplying within the virus host and
spreading throughout the population if a
virus is too virulent it might kill its
host too quickly giving it less time to
infect more people ebola is far deadlier
than covid
but covert has killed far more people
because it's less virulent and much more
contagious at the other end of the scale
we have the viruses that make up the
common cold they're usually not too
virulent which means the chances of
death or serious illness for the host
are low and the host is more likely to
carry on life as normal giving the virus
more chance to spread to other hosts the
downside for these viruses though is
that they don't establish themselves
strongly in their hosts so most people's
immune systems will recover fairly
quickly and start fighting back
the zombie virus is a little bit
different seeing as it kills pretty much
everybody it infects we can assume it's
incredibly virulent
but in this case killing the host
doesn't stop the virus from spreading in
fact
quite the opposite
the resulting zombie becomes a tireless
virus spreading machine
but how that transmission happens is
also really important
most zombies in popular culture pass the
virus on through direct physical contact
like biting that's a plus for us because
diseases that are communicated
indirectly can spread far far faster
think of something like tuberculosis
which is an airborne disease
flu that spread through droplets when
someone sneezes or malaria that moves
through vector transmission which is
when a carrier in this case a mosquito
transfers a disease from one animal to
another the fact that zombies have to
get in your personal space to turn you
into one of them is pretty terrifying
but it's actually kind of a good thing
it's easier to escape from a zombie than
it is from some microscopic droplets
floating in the air all around you your
chances are also related to the
incubation time of the disease which is
the amount of time between being bitten
and being fully changed into a zombie in
world war z the novel it's anywhere from
six hours to a week in the movie version
it's a matter of seconds and in most
other comic books films and shows it's
somewhere in between whatever the
incubation time is you basically have
that long to get the hell away from a
freshly bitten victim would you be able
to outrun zombies though scholars
disagree on this particular point in the
walking dead zombies generally move
slowly but in the movie world war z they
travel at a sprint in the living dead
trilogy they're slow in dawn of the dead
they're fast
either way what's the best way to react
generally there are four main ways to
respond to the spread of a virus hygiene
and sanitation
quarantine
vaccination and eradication
since washing your hands is unlikely to
be a big zombie deterrent no matter how
many times you sing the happy birthday
song i think we can take hygiene and
sanitation off that list
vaccination could slow the spread of the
zombie virus but you'd still be at risk
of being bitten and partially devoured
by a zombie
which is a sub-optimal outcome from a
public health perspective besides even
if vaccination made us 100 immune
it would set up a pretty awkward
situation in which we'd all be
continuing with life as normal whilst
zombies still roamed about
raising tricky questions like do zombies
have rights and should zombies be paid a
minimum wage
no it seems to me our only two options
are quarantine and eradication the
eradication part is generally thought to
be done via a shot to the head or being
set on fire so let's assume those two
work and move on what should be the best
way to approach quarantine rounding up
potentially millions of zombies would be
fairly tough so quarantine in this case
would probably look more like hiding in
terror until all the zombies have gone
away but
where should you hide
researchers at cornell university tried
to answer this exact question a few
years ago i have no idea why academics
are dedicating so much time to this by
the way to better understand how real
diseases spread they built a statistical
model of a zombie plague and predicted
how it would spread across the united
states
not surprisingly they found anyone
living in a high-density urban
environment was basically walking zombie
food the virus would spread so quickly
that few would escape but once the virus
began to move into rural areas its
spread would slow down due to the sparse
population in their example the cornell
researchers predicted it would take a
full month for zombies to move from new
york city to upstate new york the
studies findings identify remote places
like the rocky mountains or pretty much
anywhere in canada as the types of
places you'd want to be when the zombies
come which is why i'm broadcasting this
video from a cave in siberia you can't
be too careful when it comes to having
your intestines ripped out by a walking
corpse
of course when the human population is
decimated there'll be nobody left to run
basic services like energy production so
whether you're hiding out in the city or
the mountains
you'll need some pretty solid survival
skills if you're suddenly getting the
urge to pause this video and watch some
bear grylls clips i understand the study
was stochastic in design which means it
factored in a reasonable degree of
randomness to make the results more
realistic interestingly depending on the
exact parameters sometimes the zombies
won and sometimes the humans won though
whatever the ultimate outcome the
picture still didn't look all that good
for us but don't be down-hearted there's
no reason you shouldn't be able to dodge
the odds as long as you have a shotgun
and ammunition food and clothing and the
ability to build shelter and make fire
you'll be fine just pack your bags and
head for the hills
oh and be sure to take 97 random
strangers with you as you'll know if
you've watched my video on the dangers
of inbreeding projections suggest that
98 unrelated people that's 49 breeding
pairs would be the minimum number
required to restart a human population
on a distant planet
recommendations are to aim for 500 but
really trying to convince 250 women to
head off and live in the mountains with
me would never work
trust me i've tried
if you need any more tips on how to get
ready for the great zombie takeover
please contact the pentagon they have an
official document titled conop
8888 also known as counter zombie
dominance
that maps out what the us military would
do to protect non-zombie humans from
threats posed by a zombie horde
including chicken zombies vegetarian
zombies and evil magic zombies military
representatives claim the document is
only a creative tool for training
purposes but it still raises the
question if the pentagon is getting
ready for zombies
why aren't you
thanks for watching
good news you can now pre-order my new
book bread and circuses what did the
romans ever do for us it's a wild and
witty journey for a thousand years of
unexpected roman history
told in a refreshing way and packed full
of incredible and unbelievable stories
copies are selling out fast so pre-order
yours today to lock it in thank you